hi I'm Rebecca and my question is what
would happen if we traveled over the
speed of light hi Rebecca
so you asked what happens or would
happen if you could travel faster than
the speed of light
you obviously know that Einstein told us
the speed of light was a limiting
velocity and what that means is that you
can't travel faster than the speed of
light and the reason you can't is that
it would take an infinite amount of
energy to speed you up to the speed of
light so for you know we accelerate
protons and these big accelerators and
smash them together the protons and
these big accelerators with enormous
expenditure of energy have been
accelerated to almost the speed of light
99.999999% of the speed of light and
that requires a lot of energy but even
to go from that velocity which is very
close to the speed of light to the speed
of light would require another infinite
expenditure of energy so you cannot be
accelerated to the speed of light unless
you have an infinite amount of energy to
spend the only thing that does travel at
the speed of light are particles which
have no mass and they always traveled
the speed of light now people have
hypothesized that there might exist
particles which we've never seen that
travel faster than the speed of light
and in imagining such objects
immediately gets you into all sorts of
problems given everything else we know
about how the universe works given such
particles you could communicate backward
in time and that leads to all sorts of
causal inconsistencies you could go back
and do things in the past that would
change the present which doesn't make
so most of those ideas are not taken
very seriously and it is as far as we
know going to continue to be impossible
to accelerate ordinary matter to
velocities of light not speak of
velocities faster than the speed of
light